that's how I think of them if you think
pan or two for the 38th time like
[ __ ] eat [ __ ] for 30 days help me
I'm helping you every step of the way
[Music]
what's our Katrine
quick day trip to Baltimore for a client
yeah feeling pretty good about it we've
got to spend time with the new office of
the CEO which is good except for mayor
Bell we missed missed you and just
making every minute count
got a hack a calendar if you want to win
we're gonna have real time positions
that head this is the framework and I'm
gonna start really like like we're gonna
you're gonna draw this in here to show
every piece of everything you have 30
minutes 20 minutes could be 20 minutes
better reverse engineer yourself I know
that I'm not overly productive on train
trips I would have done a lot of social
media and reply and that's productive
because I want to be a flame am base but
right now I'm in the depths of
organizing a lot of really exciting
changes at vaynermedia
and there's being pan or two for the
38th time like [ __ ] eat [ __ ] for 30
days help me
I'm helping you every step of the way
that was super productive
is there a car for us hmm
whatever just take a taxi okay yeah
daddy rocket you can film them or what I
can't take it away it seems as if my
song is final say facing you make a ball
steady hit the bench every time you beat
for me to have a little thing be for me
to ever feel the shame I felt before for
me got it I'm gonna announce that will
go beyond strategy we are
Joe pleasure thank you thank you
[Music]
awesome really nice to meet you man
thank you thanks for watching very
productive super I mean to just watch
the vibe of the team and myself as we
got off the train just getting that
accomplished what we had - that was like
whoa that's my biggest piece of advice
relook at the world why can't you have
meetings when you work out why can't you
pay the extra to have somebody fly with
you to get what you have to get done
doesn't seem right on paper because it's
a checker move no that's not what you do
but in reality if you play chess oh wait
a minute makes sense financially it's
really like private drivers or private
flights or other things took me a little
while to get over the emotion of that's
douchey I came from the streets I don't
want to sell out - wait a minute that's
a that's a smart move for the value of
my time so you have something to get
done get it done you know
why can't you work on Sunday and take
off Monday and be with your family
yeah I'll be the theme of this episode
[Music]
like reverse engineering the tasks like
we need to make money this or that way
or even telling people you need to make
money this way or that way so yeah very
comfortable in that environment can
really depends on depends on the clients
grub like he's been listening but now
one to listen directly
so so so for me I'm not rich it's
basically like digital consulting hours
that's reverse engineer into what the
task at hand is we respond with that
normally against a belief but I think
for you and if you need me to come down
I'll come down Oh terrific
[Music]
it's really funny this is this is
ironically like a selfish episode like
I'm trying to make this episode even for
me yeah yes like I don't do this a lot
we don't pump they did this yeah this
was dim changing straight-up like this
could have been drugged there's been
things that have dragged out two or
three months because I wasn't able of
the slot where I could have done this
trains especially good being for people
meetings in a plane it's a little harder
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk CEO of
vaynermedia I'm pretty excited about
like people opening this video and
seeing this set up of these characters
I'm very excited about announcing an
initiative that I've been debating for a
very long time the four wonderful people
here that I'm allowed to introduce and
say a quick little thing let's keep it
very very short because you can just
email them are part of a new division
that I've decided to create called
office of the CEO basically I want the
organization to understand that when
you're talking to them you're talking to
me and when they're talking they're
pretty much pretty much talking as me I
just want to hedge that because I'm
gonna give them plenty of rain to
execute our thing but I'm always here
and we were ready to roll this out and
see the impact
don't world changing